um
we were talking about mushrooms earlier
yes talk to me about
the craziest trip you've had because a
lot of people take mushrooms they micro
dose and they get through their day and
then there's other
you do that uh what do they call it the
master dose or the
no no no like the super dose yeah it's
supposed to change your life like the
god
yeah the god dose or something [ __ ] i
don't know yeah like
like what's that what's the deepest like
craziest trip you've ever been on
and would you get out of it uh it's
probably when i ate mushrooms with my
mom we went to coachella
and i didn't know how to really dose it
all like that so i took a [ __ ] ton and
she took a lot of them too
and outcast was playing and we just have
like this cool relationship with outkast
because
when she we would go on road trips we
would always listen to equipment so i
was like
top five album all time oh yeah hell
yeah so we're like outcast coachella
we're doing shrooms hell yeah and we
took the shrooms and they were
really really really really really
really really strong and
we were both just like laying down in
the grass and [ __ ] like that
and it was cool it wasn't too much but i
couldn't move i didn't want to move
and i think the the deepest and realest
thing that i took away from that was
just the fact that i
at one point was inside of my mother's
stomach and i was like wow we were like
connected you know what i mean
like so when we were laying down i'm
like we're basically doing the same
thing we're used to hitting us the same
because we're the same
[ __ ] person i'm like this is this is
deep bro
and you know you're always going to be
cool with your mom
of course but that's another thing and
your mom for people who don't know
like wiz's mom will be at the functions
for sure like your mom's
your mom's a g for sure for sure so it
just yeah it definitely gave me a cool
ass appreciation for
for moms